the state federal veterans committee we
started on time it's actually 10:01 uh
representative Lev would you lead us in
please Al to the FL of the United States
of America to the rep stands one
nation indivisible with liy and justice
for
all
okay thank you i' like to welcome
everyone here who is uh at this working
session I want to make clear as I can uh
that this is not a hearing this is a
working
session um the reason we have a lot of
pink cards is for our uh administrative
purposes to make sure that we know what
potential resources are here that we can
recognize to help us understand uh the
different sides to this issue issue HB
229 uh which is with regard
to not allowing our National Guard New
Hampshire National Guard to be activated
uh short of a declaration of war and so
our clerk representative Kerrie
appreciates uh these pink cards for uh
clerk purposes the cards will not be
turned in uh as as they would be during
a hearing so just so that is clear
um so we will uh so we're not o obliged
to recognize anyone again this is a
working session but I appreciate you
being here and we will be looking to uh
um have some of you amplify or help us
to better understand some of the points
of this before we go to Executive
session executive session is scheduled
for 10:30 which means we can't go there
until 10:30 but I am quite sure that we
will go well past 10:30 uh as we try to
make sure we understand every piece of
this before we go to Executive session
uh I want to welcome the substitutes we
have today representative Horgan uh
there he is uh welcome representative
Horan representative Schultz are you in
the house representative Schulz is going
to be listed or is listed as a sub uh I
do not see her yet represent
torski welcome glad you're
here okay all that said and done let's
uh let's get to it I'd i' like to lead
off um looking at these pink cards
here yeah Kevin Grady uh representing as
uh Mr Grady Kevin if you could just uh
confirm for the record uh your name and
who whom you're representing then if you
could talk to to us about uh presumably
esvac position on HB 229 yes Mr chairman
happy to do that for the record my name
is Kevin Grady I am a 25- year veteran
of our Air Force I am also a 25y year
veteran of the town of hookit uh where
we moved uh when I uh finished active
duty uh back in
'98 uh today I'm representing the state
veterans advisory committee we're a
chartered by state law uh we have 20
members to speak for the veteran
community in New Hampshire and every
year as chairman of their legislative
committee I look through all the bills
that have better an impact we take a
position on them and then I come and I
tell you all what our position is on
that uh we unanimously uh oppose this
legislation uh we uh took another vote
last Tuesday to see if we wanted to
revisit our position on this and we
again were unanimously opposed uh to
this legislation um I want to start out
by saying that that title 10 of US law
is really uh the uh the guard rails here
it it governs how Reserve forces which
the na New Hampshire National Guard is
are called up and activated uh to active
military service uh for those of you
that are really not that familiar with
the military I will tell you one thing
that should should sort of be in your
thought process as you think about this
okay when we have someone off the street
walk in to our National Guard or our
Army National Guard okay the first thing
that we do with that person is we send
them to basic training okay that person
goes to Regular active duty basic
training there's no such thing as a
guard basic training okay same thing for
their follow-on skill position they
train right alongside of their
counterparts who are on active duty you
literally cannot tell the difference in
a in any given room and that's the same
relationship that we have if guard and
Reserve forces are called to active duty
by the National command Authority in
accordance with title 10 they move in
right alongside their active duty folks
they are essentially active duty people
they're paid like active duty people and
and and they go from there um we we we
have a problem in this bill with the
idea that that that Congress hasn't done
their job because we haven't declared
boore since
1943 and while acknowledging that that
is in fact true okay we also have to
acknowledge that 81 years have passed
since then okay back in 1942 we had to
have when it was a call to war we had to
activate the entire economy Rosie the
Riveter went to the went to the uh
factories because there weren't enough
men because why the men were drafted and
off they went to war people were told I
know you'd like to make truck tires but
you've got to make airplane
tires as the world's Premier economic
superpower and arguably the world's
Premier military superpower we don't
need to do that anymore and so how does
Congress exercise their control over
this because they control the money and
as a result of the Vietnam experience
the Congress decided to take some of
that control back with the with the War
Powers Resolution which was passed in
November of 1973 over President Nixon's
veto by the way just so that you know
they overrode his veto and it became law
and it basically says if you're going to
send folks out somewhere for more than
60 days with a 30-day redeployment
period you've got to come tell us what
you're doing and and otherwise we'll cut
the money off so if you look at recent
history President George HW Bush got a
an authorization to use military force
before Desert Storm President George W
bush got authorizations to use military
force before operations in Afghanistan
and Iraq now Congress could take that
authorization back anytime they want to
the fact that they haven't is not not a
discussion for for your committee
necessarily okay that's that's one for
everything else um there isn't any
difference when a soldier gets called to
active duty and it's not optional from
the guard and the active Force okay
after Desert Storm when we downsized all
of the militaries the garden Reserve
forces became a musthave and not a nice
to have back in the day when I was in
the Air Force millions of years ago okay
what did the guard have for airplanes
they had the airplanes the active duty
didn't want anymore okay what does our
guard have for airplanes they got the KC
46 the latest and greatest tanker in the
Air Force okay there are plenty of KC
135 pilots flying an airplane that's
twice as old as they are out there right
now that wish they were flying those KC
46s same song across the border in
Vermont flying the F35 over there so the
garden Reserve forces because we're
going to need them on an occasional
basis to support our operations are
equipped with our latest and greatest
Munitions and they're trained at active
duty schools so that there is no seam
between a guard person and an active
duty
person so everybody should know when
they sign on to the guard and the
reserve that there's an not there's a
possibility that you're going to end up
in a combat zone and that could happen
if whether we declare war or not so it
it it's a little bit of a distinction
without a difference um because the
national command Authority has this
ability to call these folks up because
the governor is not in the loop on that
the governor gets
consulted for for regular scheduled
deployments the governor knows a couple
years out and everybody's all on the
same page it's not like we're trying to
to hide anything here but the guard and
the reserve forces that we have in our
country right now are must-have and and
we can't have a you know a regulation
that says we're we're not going to
follow what the federal statutes are
okay at the end of the day our our
opposition in the state veterans
advisory committee is a lot about we're
rule followers we're in the military
forever the military has rules when this
when this is what the rule says we
follow the rules okay the place to
change title 10 of US law if we want to
make that change is at the federal level
it's not at the state level okay you
know the we've got those great airplanes
over at peas you know
um could they do that job from Cape cot
or Portland sure they could sure they
could okay we're all we're all kidding
ourselves if we don't think that they
couldn't okay but what we also don't
want to do we don't want to create I'm
in the guard so I'm special I'm in the
guard so I shouldn't have to go and take
my turn in the barrel like the active
duty guy even though I'm going to be on
active duty when I do that I shouldn't
have to do that we we don't want to we
don't want to send that message and I
think that's what that's what the state
veterans advisory committee would like
you to know today is that we have to
follow the rules it's clearly written
down in plain English in title 10 of US
law and if you want to change this
you've got to change it at the federal
level so subject to any of your
questions sir I'll get off the stage and
let somebody else
speak thank you Mr Grady so you said you
would take questions yes sir and and I
have several and we and so does let's
start here with uh with representative
sorry thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh when you mentioned
in your in your testimony here you say
that we follow the rules in the United
States Constitution that the delegated
power for war making is very is
explicitly outlined and handed to
Congress for the exact purpose that uh
the people should be the ones to with
this uh the last voice when it comes to
the uh War making ability do do you
believe that us right now using aums are
following the rules
I do I I believe that that Congress has
the ability at any is there only one
person I must did I turn this off if I
did I'm sorry uh you okay um the the the
Congress has the ability to withdraw an
aumf at any time they've authorized the
one since 2001 to fight the global war
on terror basically wherever if they
want to make modifications to that if
they want to do anything with that they
can they can do that
tomorrow
follow up follow so the the so when when
the Congress uh passed the War Powers
Resolution they have now subd delegated
their constitutional authority over to
the executive branch which is arguably
and the argument of this entire bill is
that that is unconstitutional so 81
years of us not following the
Constitution since World War II you
would not see that as a conflict I I I
would argue on the other side that the
the tonen Gulf resolution that was
passed in
1964 was essentially Congress giving the
president a blank check to go out and do
whatever he decided to do and the War
Powers Act of 1973 was Congress deciding
that's a bad idea we have to retain that
capability in the Congress and so
therefore we're going to pass laws that
are are realistic okay nobody nobody
there was no such thing as an aircraft
carrier or something like that back when
the the founding fathers wrote this
document nobody realized the global
reach and Global power that we have from
our Naval and Air Forces anywhere in the
world and so it's not like we have to
wait you know and build up an army and
and and have it send it on a on a six
week sale to get it somewhere okay we've
got forces all over the world that can
be ready to protect our interests on a
moment's notice and I think that that
that was a an attempt by the Congress to
say okay wait a minute we understand you
have a job to do Mr President uh but we
need to be able to control this to some
degree we're just not giving you a blank
check anymore and I think that's what
they did did with that act excellent
another followup another
followup all right this thing does turn
itself off so the uh as you mentioned
the blank check of the Gulf of tonen
resolution the 2001 aumf is very
arguably a clone of that exact thing
there's no outlined um targets there's
no outlined Victory conditions no
outlined countries we've used it as an
excuse to invade over 22 countries and
largely classified this is not exposed
not visible to the American taxpayer uh
We've uh caused coups and other
countries with the training with the
money used under the 2001 aumf you don't
see that as as a repeat of the mistake
70s again representative I I keep having
to go back to the fact that that if the
Congress of the United States allows
this to go to happen which which they
have by this a aumf then you know could
you end up with situations like this you
know the countries you're talking about
they there there weren't any incursion
that are there couldn't be any urss
longer than 60 days of significant
amounts of forces without again going
back to the going back to the Congress
and getting an authorization uh a
specific authorization for that action
so I I think I think the
aumf could could we do things to make
that stronger and more limited certainly
okay is is that our place to to
legislate that from down here in conquer
we don't think so we think that place to
legislate that is in DC with our elected
co-sponsor thank you representative
recognized um thank you for being with
us as always
um United States has a mutual defense
treaty with nor with South Korea and we
have thousands a troop stationed in
Korea as we know in
1951 Kim jong's grandfather invaded
South
Korea to to keep our American soldiers
stationed there out of he's way wouldn't
it be imperative to mobilize the
National Guard to backfill positions so
more active Dy military could go into
that combat
zone
question well well sir that that is a
that's a a question for a diplomat
probably more so I thought you were than
me no no sir I'm uh I'm just a I'm just
a lowly fighter pilot you know I want to
pass I do kind of what I'm told on that
but no the uh I I've I've never been
stationed in Korea I've been stationed
on okanawa where our job was defense of
Korea and I've been to Korea on on
numerous occasions and and they take
their they take their sovereignty very
seriously they they land airplanes on on
on roads two or three times a year just
to prove they can do it and and so I I
understand that I think anybody that's
ever been to Korea would come back with
the same thing that how seriously they
take their own defense and for the most
part they're pretty happy to have us
there
now again a diplomat question are we are
we there to you know keep uh Kim Jong uh
un from doing something or we there to
just be there in case we need needed in
China or Taiwan or some other place
again we could get into a that's a we
followup say it's better when the mic's
off when I speak but
uh I won't ask for a vote on that but uh
this is more would you believe um in
1861 after the fall of Ford sua
President Lincoln would you believe
called up as for 75,000 volunteers to
serve in the Union forces state militias
were brought up and put into Federal
units to um to make war against the
Confederacy Congress never declared war
in the Confederate States of America do
you believe that under this if this Bill
had passed a similar circumstance that
happened in this country during the
Civil War that the New Hampshire State
militia now National Guard would have be
in the same parent not be able to uh to
come to the aid of uh our country and
our
president
because there's no decleared War I I
shouldn't think so then then that said
if you pass this bill you're now one
state out of 50 that has said we're
we're not going to follow the rules and
then we would have to see well what what
happens as a result of that you know is
there do do other states follow that do
does Congress make changes I I I don't I
can't foresee the future on that or does
somebody say well we we now we have 49
states that have the guard and Reserve
in them and you know that we have a 50th
state there that is you know it doesn't
have any forces and you know instead of
being in a position to offer our forces
to other states that have emergencies
natural disasters those kind of things
we won't be there to won't be there to
do that up here and whenever we have
something like that we're going to be
dependent on somebody else to do that
for us thank you yes sir thank you for
your service thank you
uh for the record I do want to point out
and I have been to Korea a couple times
myself uh that Korean conflict started
by Kim John ern's grandfather Kim Mong
happened in 1950 not 1951 I know that's
way before your time M
uh uh represent gag says he remembers it
so anyway uh 1950 yes uh representative
um Manion um is
recognized thank you Mr chair uh one
thing I'd point out is nothing in this
bill precludes a National Defense if we
were to be invaded or something were to
attack the Homeland that that's
completely within the the scope of the
National Guard's Mission and it would
not be affected by the the bill
whatsoever but I do have another
question the um you mentioned in your
testimony that uh uh we don't want the
state to think or Guardsmen to have this
attitude of I'm with the guard so I'm
special but the the guard does have a
dual Mission That's Unique versus the
active duty military is that
correct the the guard does have a a
Mission but but I would also argue that
their primary mission in the National
Guard is whatever their active duty
skill set is whatever their MOS for the
Army or or their Air Force specialty
code for the Air Force is their primary
job is doing that job and being ready in
case the national command Authority
needs them on either a per unit basis or
a per person basis uh to go somewhere
and and do something for the the
national command Authority so the they
do sort of have a a dual Allegiance but
um the the the one that is their is
their primary mission is whatever
whatever their skill set is for their
service before I go back to the co-art
is does anyone else uh have a question
for Mr Grady uh representative Horgan uh
we will recognize you go ahead thank you
very much Mr chair make this quick I'm
just a guest in this committee but um we
were talking about how we haven't had a
formal declaration of war since World
War II and then I guess some least some
of the pron Bill feeling that was a
mistake and against the Constitution but
what did we well first of all I guess
during World War II we actually did
start intervening and deploying assets
even before Pearl Harbor but with the uh
armed conflicts us got involved with
before that did they all have a formal
declaration of war or did some of them
you know were authorized you know
somewhat informally as has been the case
since World War II with all our armed
many well you know the I I think uh
President Truman took great pains to say
that this is not a war in Korea it's a
police action under the United Nations
uh I'm not a real historian on on
Vietnam I probably should be a little
more than I am but that's sort of
evolved and ramped up after the tonen
Gulf resolu ution in ' 64 um I was in I
was in junior high in high school uh
back then and and missed out on that
conflict but um the the stuff since then
Desert Storm I think there was a pretty
clear purpose for what we were doing
there the there was originally a a
purpose for the Iraq and the uh and the
Afghanistan uh arrange or in you know
incursions um at at some point in time
it's my personal opinion Kevin Grady's
opinion not shared by the svac or DOD or
any of those other people or Taylor
Swift's folks uh but the you know at
some point we may have lost our way a
little bit and included a lot of things
in in the aumf as representative Manion
says that that really and truly weren't
specific to the original purpose of why
we were doing what we were doing back in
2001 that said again the persons that
the people that need to change that are
Congress at that
level to representative Horgan's point
there have been numerous times that we
have uh post World War I we went to uh
Haiti
Nicaragua uh we're in Lebanon in 1957
and in 1983 when in in Lebanon so there
have been many numerous occasions where
we have used we deployed and used Force
short of a declaration of war R Manan uh
you had you hand up sure uh thank you Mr
chair I just have some questions about
the structure of the svac so the um the
the s back mission statement is what
what would you say that their primary
purpose is their their primary purpose
is is is is kind of generally so that
we've got one one one voice that speaks
for the veteran community in New
Hampshire and we have 20 member
organizations that do that um I can read
them to you if you want or I can yes I
would actually like the list if you if
you can read them out loud into the
record we have the uh the Air Force
Association or now the air and space
forces Association which I represent we
have the air sergeants Association the
American Legion the uh the a
USA Catholic War veterans Catholic
veteran motorcycle association Disabled
American Veterans Korean War veterans
association the Marine Corps League the
Military Officers Association of America
the military order of the Purple Heart
the National Guard Association of New
Hampshire the New Hampshire Army retiree
Council the New Hampshire guard enlisted
Association the New Hampshire veterans
association Patriot resilient leader
Institute uh the reserve Officers
Association Rolling Thunder the veterans
of Flor and War and the Vietnam Veterans
of America those are our 20 members of
the svac and I'd be happy to leave this
you may have been sent our annual report
by uh by our chairman back there Paul
Lloyd and it this is Pages three and
four of from that annual
report thank you
followup another followup go ahead so
the uh Department of military Affairs
and veteran services were only recently
combined into a single Department in the
in the State uh and that was in 2019 do
you know why that
was uh I'll give you just a little
history um when governor sonunu was
first elected governor sununu walked
into uh one of our state veterans
advisory committee meetings and his
first question was one we couldn't
answer he went if I have a problem a
veteran comes to me with a problem where
do I send him and we said well we
imagine that between the state veterans
advisory committee and a lot of our uh
people that are that meet with us all
the time we probably get the answer to
that but there really wasn't what he
would call a single belly button that he
could push to to get things done or or
ask a veteran related question and that
led to about two or three years worth of
legislation and bills that finally
culminated in in the uh it finally
culminated in standing up the department
of military Affairs and vetor services
to sort of put all of the people that
are trying to do good things for
veterans all Under One Roof uh in that
were was commanded by the agitant
general and if if if uh Colonel Perry
has anything different he'd like to add
okay uh ranan as a co-sponsor I would
giv you some extra latitude here and U
and thank you again uh Mr Grady for
speaking of front I think right up front
here we're getting a lot of the
questions asked and answered that we all
need to hear um and we so we'll continue
to with that process I do have a lot of
pink cards that are coming my way uh and
I need to again remind everybody this is
not a public hearing we've had a public
hearing on February 3rd for this um the
purpose of of uh the working session is
what's happening right here is to get
some folks with some specific
information that'll help the committee
to better evaluate the the bill in in
totto before we have an exact session so
uh we'll come back to this and there are
some of the folks especially as a
courtesy to uh representatives and
former Representatives uh we will give
them certainly a chance to to speak but
again if if you're desire to speak is
simply to do what you may may have
already done on February 3rd and just
say you're in favor of the bill that's
not why we're here we're looking for
What's Happening Here is specific
information to help us uh EXA this bill
later today so that said uh repes Manion
uh you're on again thank you Mr chair
sorry for all these follow-ups I I have
a lot of questions the uh so the svac
purpose is to be the a singular voice of
the veterans uh I think a lot of people
in this committee have been been
receiving uh lots and lots of phone
calls emails from the veteran Community
specifically in support of this bill do
did did anybody of those any of those
voting members did they poll their
member basee to see if they any of the
people that they allegedly represent uh
support this or not I I I know that a p
committer of the BFW is here uh that
maybe can speak to that I know
within my organization I I pulled the
members and I I didn't get I didn't get
anybody who's uh who spoke in favor of
this I got I only and to be fair I only
got about 10 or 12 responses but they
were all we support we support what the
svic position is on
this uh question for me uh Mr Grady uh
did I I hear you correctly did you and
thank you for I was going to ask the
same question that the representative
from pelum asked terms of esac State
veterans advisory committee who makes
that up and you thank you uh you
answered that that there's 20 different
components to your committee uh did I
hear you correctly did you say earlier
that the committee itself when it met
was unanimously opposed to the bill did
I hear that correctly we we we we met we
talked about representative Manuel was
at the at the at the meeting representa
Manning was was given time to speak uh
he engaged in some and I I don't think
I'm speaking out of turn here you
engaged in some questions with uh some
members of the audience to get some
clarification then we went on with the
rest of our meeting structure when it
got to my point is with the legislative
session and I started talking about the
15 bills we're going to follow for the
next session but then I also said hey
I've got a hearing next Wednesday and if
we're going to change our position
because that's why representative Manion
was at our meeting was to see if the
svac would either one withdraw our
objection or number two support the bill
and we we threw this thing open and
chairman Lloyd there in the back uh
asked three times do there any
discussion is there any move to change
our position on this bill and there was
no there was no movement in it at all so
I I take that to be a
unanimous uh unanimous consent if you
will because we did not want to revisit
our position on this thank you
gagy first of all thank you Mr Grady for
remaining in the hot seat and you're
answering the questions well I remember
Korea I was eight years old seven eight
years old and I followed the union
leader with the little arrows as we were
as we were being pushed by the Chinese
towards a chosen Reservoir and all that
good
stuff during an undeclared war um you
talked about we have to follow the rules
and most of me agrees with that
following the rules but if there's
enough push back do you think perhaps
the people making the rules to kind of
sort of review the rules and and and
tweak those rules so that it would be
more advantageous all the way around
including those who serve who are called
up every six months or every year to
give up their jobs and their families
and go there to another hot spot and
they come back back home for a couple
years then they go back to another hot
spot should shouldn't like the rules
change maybe we could stop my
opinion in my opinion we should stop
being the police policeman of the world
and and going in there and try
to get involved with things maybe we
shouldn't get involved with
thank well sir there's a there's a lot
to unpack of that question um and but I
guess what I would tell you is
um if if we shouldn't be wandering
around the world to your point sir being
the world's
policemen then we then our active duty
guys shouldn't be doing that either
neither should our our guard forces and
we shouldn't be making this distinction
where we are just going to say we're not
going to go because we're we're we're in
the guard and the active duty guy is
going to go and and I think a lot of
what you saw if you look back to the for
example the the incursion into uh into
Iraq in 2003 okay you know by the time
by the time we started to send the guard
and Reserve forces in there most of the
active duty units had been in there two
maybe three times had already made two
or three trips over there and then it
was time to sort of start blending in
these uh units and at at one point I I
read the in the your your Journal
article at one point we had like 60% of
the people that were in country there
were were Garden Reserve forces well the
timing on that kind of worked works out
to be about their turn about once every
two or three times that the active duty
folks have to go but again we're we're
we're opposed to this distinction you
know without a difference because when
you get called up to active duty via
tile 10 you're you're on active duty as
much as the active duty Soldier next to
you and while you might think you have a
a mission back home right now your
primary mission is supporting whatever
the national command Authority needs you
to do and it's just as inconvenient for
that active duty kid from New Hampshire
not to be here when they're needed by
the state as it is for the guard guy in
our
opinion representative Manion yes so you
mentioned during the uh the uh 60% of
the people being deployed during one of
those instances it was uh the Louisiana
National Guard in particular do did you
know that they were deployed to Iraq
when Katrina hit and they were not
state again you know I I I wasn't
specifically foll following them and I
don't think that Katrina at least big
picture-wise you know U would they have
not sent those guys if Katrina had hit a
month or two months before they were
deployed that's a possibility that they
might have tried to work something else
out but you know once you're once you're
in position over there and you have a
disaster back home then what has to
happen is the folks that are still home
have to do it and you've got to rely on
your neighbors to come in and help you
same thing that you know we did the
floods in Vermont we sent our Blackhawk
k opter is over there to help them
because we rely on our neighbors to to
do those things for us when you know
they either don't have the capability or
Health other questions for Mr
Grady who has been on the hook uh for
quite a while thank you for your stamina
I have one quick one uh uh Kevin we have
uh a bill that's in the hopper with ol
is going to come to us uh in January
with regard to uh funding for increas in
recruiting bonuses for the guard uh and
we're quite aware that the guard has had
a tough time uh as has have most
services around the country have had a
very tough time with recruiting it's
part of the reason behind the bill that
we're going to get um so I've heard it
said that some folks uh want to join the
guard because as opposed to a a federal
service because they like the mission of
the Guard the guard is focused on uh New
Hampshire um and of course has already
been pointed out National Guards have
certainly been used in in a federal
capacity
but the notion that Guardsmen New
Hampshire Guardsmen may be deployed I
have heard that that has been has had a
chilling effect on at least some folks
who don't want to join don't join the
gardo because they they don't want to
deploy could you speak to that have you
heard much along those
lines again I'm not I'm
not in on all the recruiting efforts and
all those other things and and to your
the point of this bill that's going to
come in you know we're we in the svac
would always like to be able to help our
our guard folks out to recruit people I
believe that uh that that our members of
the the svac are probably our best
recruiters people that have have have
served in the military are some of our
best influencers is the term we would
use in my other line of work as a as a
ad missions liaison officer for the Air
Force Academy you know that those we
folks are are are influencers that way
um some of this stuff again you know if
you if you were to go to peas for
example and look at the tanker operation
over there we've we've got an active
duty Squadron there stood up right next
to the tanker Squadron the crews are
interchangeable they're doing a real
world mission every single day okay so I
would submit to you that those folks
over there in the Air National Guard at
peas are focused on their their their
title 10 Mission and less focused on you
know what can I do for the State of New
Hampshire the big thing about about if
you want to serve in the in a branch of
the service and you want to be taught a
skill by that branch and you want a lot
of the things that people like about
military service camaraderie those kind
of things and you want the ability to be
always stationed your entire life in New
Hampshire you don't have to do like I
don't if if many of you were probably on
active duty in the military and every
three years you pick up and move
someplace else because it's your turn in
the barrel to move someplace else you
know this is a you know joining the
garden the big draw there is if you love
New Hampshire you're going to be in New
Hampshire now are you occasionally going
to have to do the real world mission
that you were that you're trained to do
yes at some point you're probably going
to have to do that and that's just
something that I think our recruits need
to understand when they walk in the door
is that there's a there's always the
possibility you're going to be called
upon to do your real world
mission we don't necessarily know where
that's going to
be thank you anything else from Mr
Grady Mr gr thank you for your uh uh
patience and for answering all these
questions I think we knocked off a lot
of the uh pieces of this that we need to
knock off as way we allowed the
co-sponsor uh so much latitude in asking
numerous questions uh so we want to move
right along and again I will repeat we
have a lot of folks who do want to weigh
in we appreciate you being here and
we'll we'll try to honor that if we can
but I need to remind you this is not a
hearing uh you folks Mr Grady is here
for our pleasure to help us to give this
measure uh full do consideration when we
execute later later on so if uh those of
you who want to speak if all you wanted
to do was just say your in favor of the
bill I'm going to ask you to uh to not
do that uh um in fact unless you have
something new or Salient or relevant
that's going to help us something that
hasn't come up just now or earlier uh
again I need to make sure you understand
this is a working session not a hearing
that said I'd like to recognize the
representative from J representing
Jaffrey ringe in Dublin representative
Senate
senat
saso uh repes representative senat taso
welcome thank you chairman do a much
better job than the
speaker um so the uh the question about
section 10 and our compliance with it
this bill doesn't do anything to take us
out of compliance section 10 uh National
Guard troops will still go to basic
training that's funded by the federal
government and they'll stand ready to be
deployed and Destroy uh the enemies of
the United States of America just as
they do now um it's just says that we're
going to um do it if there's a
declaration of war uh now the am a
authorized use of military force
questions coming up and people are
debating whether or not that's a
declaration of war or not uh but this
bill doesn't doesn't discuss that it
just says it has to be a declaration of
war so that's you know is it a
declaration of war or not you know I
tend to think it's not but that's a
question for the courts uh we're just
saying it needs to be declaration War
which is already the US is already US
Constitution so you know the federal
government seems to believe it's
declaration of war uh and if that's what
it is then that's what it is but you
know we're just putting our guard in and
we're just saying that it has to also be
a declaration war from our perspective
um so there would be no changes to to
our compliance with title 10 uh I hope
that makes
sense um and then uh
just you know pulling funds uh
forfeiture of funds and all this stuff
is is highlighted in title 32 so so you
know it's not even a title 10 issue um
but it's not relevant we're going to be
in compliance with title
10 um so that's just what I want to do
is first reframe it into what the actual
question is any
questions
yes perhap a
shli thank you uh Mr chairman and that
comment about the speaker is the current
current Speaker you were referring to
about the uh Excellence of our chair of
this Committee just for the record um uh
from everything I've read if we were
attacked today Congress can't declare
war can today because we don't have a
speaker they could take no formal action
they couldn't even do a resolution in
support of the people of Israel so what
would happen today are you asking if the
Hampshire would declare war according
I'll be clarifying I thank you for being
here if the United States if someone
attacked the United States we could not
activate the National Guard without a
declaration of war from Congress as of
today the United States Congress cannot
take any action because they don't have
a
speaker okay so I mean it doesn't if
it's illegal to deploy troops or not is
the question right uh does the am the
authorized use of military force is that
could what I'm trying to say is if it's
legal to deploy troops under am
authorized use of military Force you
know this doesn't a this isn't deciding
whether or not it's legal this isn't the
question it's just it has to be a
declaration of war so when it comes time
to deploy troops you know the governor
has to uh you know title 10 says it
actually says it has to be lo you know
we have to comply with it it for legal
uh lawful uh call UPS to war um when he
calls the troops in you know we'll have
to decide the court will have to decide
whether that was legal or not if the if
it was a authorized use of military
force whether if Congress can't declare
war and there's other ways of deploying
troops uh like it was alluded to earlier
uh in World War I they were deployed
before um there was a declaration of war
there's like a 60 day thing or something
uh then that's
fine follow up follow follow
up well then why are we entertaining
this bill if there are other ways to
activate the National Guard for 60 days
then what is the sense of this bill
because this bill says upon a
declaration of war by Congress then the
National Guard can go into
combat right so you could say I mean
what's the point of this bill there's a
the Constitution already says we need a
declaration of war right Congress
authorizes the War uh but some people
believe that they're not they're not in
compliance with that they believe that
the the authoriz use military force is
not a declaration of war um but to ask
that question we we can't ask that we
can't answer that question here you know
people are trying to decide what does
does it imply that it's not a
declaration War that's what the that's
what the bill implies but we're we're
not we're not the court we're not going
to decide that if it's legal or not okay
thank
you other questions for representative
Senator Sao uh representative Manion I
actually have the answer to that
question but the nothing in this bill so
line four or line 26 section 4 says
nothing in this bill shall liit or
prohibit the Governor from consenting to
the deployment of National Guard member
on uh title 32 section 904 that includes
repel Invasion and quell riots and
execute the laws of the nation this
nothing in this bill would prevent us
from defending ourselves so some of this
back and forth right here might be
better suited for executive session
y resent fenny you have a hand up
okay all right uh representative
santonastaso thank you for being here
and thank you for your testimony I'd
like to go to uh I'd like to recognize
Leon H WR out the honorable Leon h r out
uh who came all the way down from
Lancaster from the North Country uh
representing the New Hampshire VFW W
welcome uh uh
honorable uh USMC veteran R
out thank you uh and I'd like to thank
the members of the committee for
allowing me to speak today I'm Leon R
out I serve 26 years in the United
States Marine Corps from 1981 to
2007 during that time I deployed many
times most notably in 1991 for Desert
Shield Desert Storm in 2003 in support
of operation enduring freedom and again
in 2006 for Iraqi Freedom those last
three deployments were done from a
reserve
status
I also served locally on many boards as
Selectmen and I also had the honor of
serving as a state representative from
2012 to
2016 with two of those years on this
very same
committee I have recently served as a
state Commander for the Department of
New Hampshire VFW and currently serve as
New Hampshire's National councilman for
the VFW I will be testifying an
229 and broken it down since the burn
Wall came down 9 November 1989 and the
Soviet Union falling apart there's been
talk of a peace
dividend this peace dividend has been
realized by several reductions in the
forces and the restructuring of forces
that plac many support units into the
reserve and National
Guard after several rounds of draw downs
and
restructuring the guard in Reserve are
an integral part of our planning for
National
Security in 1990 the active Army had a
579,000
members today's authorized strength
ranks which we are not
meeting the Army is
485,000 the Marine Corps is
178,00 the Navy is
346,000
Air Force is down to
329,000
and we have added the space force with a
strength of
8,400 these are significant reductions
those reductions have required the
Pentagon to alter strategic
planning those shifts have involved the
National Guard in the reserves to
Forces these missions around the world
cannot be
accomplished without the National Guard
and the
reserve do not mistake mistakenly
believe any large deployment of US
troops can happen without the support of
the national guard and Reserve they are
planning I would also like to address
because there was an editorial that came
out using several things to support this
bill and I feel it's a bit
misleading it cites a story about a
Guardsman deployed in Iraq during
Hurricane
Katrina Katrina was one of the largest
disasters to hit the nation in a very
long time in the editorial would lead
one to believe that the deployment of
the Louisiana National Guard impacted
relief
efforts that just is not
accurate Louisiana has approximately
11,500 National Guardsmen which are
organized into 74
units and during the largest activation
and deployment of National Guard and
reserves during Desert Shield Desert
Storm only 17 of those units were
deployed nine of them serving on the
front
lines at no time has every National
Guardsman from a state been deployed at
the same
time that I can find and I did research
that in fact during Katrina Louisiana
National Guard pre-positioned 3,000
guardmen Guardsmen in and around New
prior to the storm hitting the Gulf
Coast even if no Guardsmen were deployed
the disaster would have overwhelmed them
and required
reinforcements it is easy to find that
within 96 hours of the storm 30,000
troops were in the area in total during
the disaster 43,000 National Guardsmen
responded to
Katrina and and
18,000 active duty troops responded to
Katrina the response was not affected by
the deployment in those troops within 96
hours they
airlifted 88,000 tons of
supplies and affected
177,000
rescues
so again the deployment of the unit and
I went to the Louisiana National Guard
site and try to find out which units
were deployed in
2006 their website has no mention of a
deployment in
2006 though I don't doubt that there
were probably Guardsmen deployed the
only thing they mention in 2006 is their
Katrina
this article also mentions a budget
alternative what is that budget
alternative I believe the author is
trying to infer that it is somehow the
cheaper to deploy a National Guard or
reserve unit compared to an active duty
unit but that again is not true those
activated must be paid the same as an
active duty unit to include housing
dependent benefits
if anything it's much more costly to
activate and deploy a guard or reserve
unit because a higher percentage of them
are married and have
families so there is no gimmick in the
budget that saves the federal government
money by deploying the National Guard or
Reserve there's talk about the executive
branch being able to unilaterally choose
military actions and theaters in order
to activate the guard Reserve units
Congress must give approval they got to
at least declare a national emergency
and they still control the pur strings
which they can shut off at any
time there is no unrestrained military
power given to the executive
branch again that's just not an accurate
statement it does talk about the threat
from the Pentagon to reduce funding for
the National Guard If This Were to pass
ass to me that seems like common sense
as a nation we strategically plan to be
able to use the guard and Reserve as
needed if that ability is taken away
from the federal government why would
same that's just a
reality part of the duty of the National
Guard is to protect the
country the reason the Federal
government gives the state so much money
to run the National Guard is so they can
necessary it was also claimed that the
opposition only comes from the Pentagon
in the New Hampshire State veterans
advisory committee which I have sat
on and in case you're not familiar the S
has its membership from every veteran
HB 229 was unanimously opposed at every
up the author did meet with the the
Hampshire esac because he wanted to give
a clearer picture of the bill from real
veterans that have experienced the
horrors of
War I don't know who we thought he was
talking to in that
room there are veterans from many eras
war and do not want to compromise
National Security with this bill matter
of fact there's hundreds of years of
military experience in that room whenin
meets they are well aware of the horrors
of war and I just want to let everyone
know that every member of the New
Hampshire esac whether whether they
served in combat or not is a real
veterans I have per personally
participated in two Wars and fully
understand the horrors of it during my
last deployment to the streets of
Fallujah I lost 11 Marine Brothers in
combat as well see over 100 earn the
Purple
Heart
war is
horrible but sending our servicemen
overseas keeps us from seeing that in
our own
land I ask the committee to itl HB
229 this is a state legislature the
state legislature should not be doing
bills that could compromise our national
security
questions represent
fny thank you to the chair I thank you
for for uh the former member for being
here and speaking today uh I have a
couple questions for you my first is who
who are we at war with
currently currently there is no declared
Wars so I follow up um if we were to
activate the National Guard of New
Hampshire to go overseas to fight who
are we fighting
right now we're generally involved in a
war on terror so it would probably be a
terrorist another followup please um
could you could you
name uh
a
legally
recognized
state that America is currently at war
with now representative just by the very
definition of
terrorist they do not necessarily have a
state that does not mean they cannot
attack us does not mean they cannot kill
American
citizens you talk to people right now
with what's going on in Israel and
they'll tell you Hamas is not
Palestine but it most definitely
is terrorists do not necessarily need a
state to act from we found out that in
2001 when we had a group working out of
Afghanistan it was not their state but
they attacked our
country other
questions uh if not I have a quick one
uh that I want to throw out there and I
think it's it's relevant uh you
mentioned 1991 uh you and I were in the
same Battalion at that time we went to
uh the Middle East went to uh Saudi
Arabia and Kuwait now at that time in
the fall of 1990 into 1991 the US Senate
had an authorization of force uh measure
that was asked for that would allow
President Bush 41 to use force in the
Middle East passed narrowly in the
Senate we were in uniform watching that
closely now later on President Bush said
having put all the having deployed all
the resources to the Middle East uh he
was going to use them anyway regardless
of whether or not the Senate approved
the measure authorizing
force uh so my question to you is what
are your thoughts on what President Bush
supposedly said that he would go ahead
and use Force anyway even in the absence
authorization personally I would have
thought that would have been wrong but
there was a lot of compromising going on
there was compromises on the budget that
year and stuff that he worked
on to make it pass I will say that is
one issue that we face right now with
the
ship in Washington
DC could we get a declaration of war
when we declared war in World War Two I
denters I don't believe that's even
possible and as was mentioned earlier
hyperarid within the parties we do not
have a house speaker right right now and
if something happened right now we would
not be able to declare war the first
thing we would have to do is select a
speaker so and I also add and this is a
big thing we haven't declared war since
1941 well one of the outcomes of World
War II was the establishment of the UN
whether you like the UN or not that is
supposedly the governing body of the
world and supposed to help control
conflicts a lot lot of what we do now is
UN anytime we have to do when we were in
the Gulf in
91 President Bush had to go to the UN
and get authorization there too so
there's several folds that the use of
through thank you uh uh one more
question that we need to roll on here go
ahead represent Manion thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question so
uh the one thing I would just mention is
uh during the um the Katrina hurricane
there was 1836 fatalities do you think
that more of those people would be alive
if more of the Guard Louisiana National
Guard were in state to help I absolutely
do
not there that was a disaster that
nobody could predict the size of it they
had already activated and pre-positioned
the guard that they thought they were
going going to
need so so whether they were there or
not first you got to figure the
destruction that happened in the
Louisiana in the surrounding
area many of the Guardsmen couldn't
respond because there weren't passable
roads or anything else the complete
power grid and communication grid was
wiped out so no I don't and I think the
response in 96 hours having over 30,000
troops there proves that no probably no
lives would have been saved if that
Louisiana uh representative
Mett question I
have is there a
situation where you would in fact
support HB
any
conflict in the current state and how we
have set up our strategic planning and
our
military I would
not again the National Guard in the
reserve is a critical part and direct
partner with our active duty forces
anytime there's a conflict and I will
say even you got a major training
exercise you're probably going to find
some active you're going to have to find
active some reserve and probably some
Guardsmen that are participating even in
a large scale exercise because so much
of the support units have been placed
into
those this has been a strategy that's
supposedly saving us money that's come
down because people wanted the defense
budget cut because the Soviet Union was
no longer a threat so the reality is our
National Guard in reserve are part of of
needed other questions saying none thank
you representative R out or former
representative honorable Leon R out all
the way from Lancaster I do have some
printed
you y okay we need to roll on here uh I
think we've largely accomplished the
intent of the working session uh I know
the co-sponsors asked numerous questions
uh that have been very helpful to those
of us in the committee to get some um uh
some more Fidelity in terms of some of
the aspects of this um I do want to
recognize some of the uh briefly
recognize some of the other
Representatives I have a lot of folks
who want to weigh in um the clock is
ticking um we'll see how quickly the uh
the elected officials can get through
what they have asked to to State and
then we will go from there uh and again
uh we're looking for something new
something that the committee you think
needs to hear that has not come up
either in in on February 3rd which was a
hearing uh or earlier today so that said
uh moving right along and hopefully
fairly quickly representative from
Northfield representative is here uh
representative
welcome thank you chairman thank you
members of the committee I'll make this
extremely quick I'm just concerned that
our National Guard is being used as
Pawns in a larger geopolitical game
played by the mega corporations Ron loed
Martin and just brief history lesson
here in the early 1800s the French
Foreign Legion was created in 1831 in
1835 they were essentially given to the
queen of Spain to fight during a
secession battle and for 3 years they
sent 4,000 troops and after three years
only 500 returned and I'm just concerned
that we've essentially sold our
neighbors into conscription for Wars in
places that the average American can't
find and I think that's extremely
dangerous problematic and only going to
increase as long as we believe that we
the latest and greatest equipment to
keep our National Guard able to do what
we have floods in New Hampshire do we
need these tankers I mean I understand
the concept but it's not really part of
the defense of New Hampshire I think we
honestly I think we have more of a
problem with Canada going full
totalitarian right now than anything
else but that's just my quick uh outake
on this and thank you any
questions okay thank you and we do need
to keep this to new information uh uh
not that we're not interested in your
opinion we technical information that
addresses the language of the measure
that we're going to shortly take up an
executive session representative
question chair uh sure represent thank
you Mr chairman I appreciate um could we
set a high time of maybe quarter 12 to
go into executive session and I don't
want to C cut off any of our current for
uh current former members of the house
that want to speak to us today but we
did have a public session and I know
some members may have commitments you
know thinking we're going to have a
10:30 EXA where they may have to leave
and not be able to vote on this bill so
that's something I would ask of the
chair thank you represent I agree uh and
that sounds like a good uh time to uh uh
wrap things up so we can go to the
scheduled executive session so we will
move right along uh until no later than
11:45 so those of you who are wishing to
weigh in again as I've said several
times uh we're looking for new
information this is not a hearing this
is a working session uh I'd like to
represent uh recognize a representative
from straford District 19 repres penzer
is thank you chair I was not able to
testify before so and I'm not going to
do that now you wanted new information
so my information is my personal
experience so in 91 I uh that's when I
graduated from high school it's also
when I signed in for the Army Reserves
um I was actually going to college so in
Massachusetts and because of that I did
a split option which they don't even
really offer anymore so I went to basic
training in the summer of 91 came back
and then I went um to Virginia for my
MOS training and I missed going to
Operation Desert Storm by two weeks I
was a water dog 77 whiskey and of course
their uh water treatment Specialists of
course are in the desert so I think that
everything that I've heard here is the
wonderful testimony but we're talking
about rules and laws the foundational
law in our country it's what we took as
representatives to the US and to the New
Hampshire
Constitution is specifically article one
section 8 that's what this bill is I I
don't it's really not rocket science for
me and if we can't have have that you
know constitutional checks and balances
then what do we have especially in New
Hampshire with what happened during coid
for example I spoke to many national
Guardsmen I have a lot of friends that
are in um that actually lost their jobs
because they were deployed here to
answer phones and to in inject our
people at you know at a racetrack if it
was it was pretty crazy during that time
so and if you don't have any sort of
checks and balances on our executive
branch here that's a problem and then
going back to what was said about not
having a speaker the president has
Authority in Congress we all know that
just like the the governor here has that
can call us all into session and we can
make decisions if there's a declaration
of war or something like that that needs
to happen so I just wanted that as a
reminder but we have have to prevent all
of these hasty decisions so requiring a
declaration of war imposes a deliberate
and formal process that necessitates
careful consideration and debate so of
course it prevents a lot of different
things in deoiling military the clarity
of purpose is another one a declaration
of war provides a clear statement of the
nation's intent and purpose in
committing military forces this Clarity
is important of course for the military
and the public but I think the most
important thing here is the public
accountability the decision to go to war
or deploy National Guards should be
transparent and an accountable process
requiring a declaration of war ensures
that elected officials are on the record
and the public can hold them accountable
for their decisions and then of course
everything about doing with casualty
risk but even if you look at our
International um law and Norms the
International Community of course around
the world generally respects that the
principle that military force should be
used is a last resort and it has to have
just cause so requiring a declaration of
war aligns with these
principles I think that the sponsors of
this bill have been clear and that
there's a lot of different things that
that scap guards but the rules rules are
not law our foundational law is our
Constitution and I think we have to
follow that every single representative
here that is going to be voting did that
to me it's very easy and I know that I
didn't I didn't uh I didn't serve in a
wartime situation but and and there's a
lot of people that did um but we have to
take these things you know
so especially with what's going on right
now it's imminent that we uh that we act
and I think that it's uh that we have to
do that thank
you thank you
welcome thank you chairman Moffett
ranking member shirtliff um I did not
get to
testify at the February her third
hearing I am a member of Criminal
Justice and as a result have to be there
most of the time I do just want to read
to you a quote by President Truman that
was given during his farewell address
that I think has to relate to this a
piece of a
quote this conjunction of an immense
military establishment and a large arms
industry is the new American Experience
the total influence economic political
and even spiritual is felt in every city
every state house every Office of the
federal government we recognize the
imperative need for this development yet
we must must not fail to comprehend its
grave
implications our toil resources and
livelihood are all involved so is the
very structure of our society in the
councils of government we must guard
against the acquisition of unwarranted
influence whether sought or unsought by
the military industrial complex the
potential for the disastrous rise of
misplaced power exists and will persist
what President Truman was warning about
in that quote is what we are dealing
with here here today 80s something years
of the country which stood for what we
thought was the moral right righteous
side in World War II what I think is the
moral righteous side galvanizing the
world and stopping the fascist Menace
but since then have used that moral
stature to destroy the world for
economic political and social means and
we have a lot of men and women here
people behind me who love this country
and want to serve it to their full
extent but cannot do that if their
service is being manipulated by the
people at the top of our military
establishment used for purposes that are
not the protection of the United States
of America and our homeland uh the
forever war that George Orwell talked
about in 1984 War the one that never
ended the one that always had a
justification the one that was always
important I think we're going through
that right now I think the so-called war
on terror the wars in Vietnam and Korea
talk to the people there's a few of them
here in this room chairman Moffett I
know you served I know there are a
number of people who have served just
talk to the other Representatives that
have spent time in Vietnam that were
there on the ground spent time in Iraq
they will tell you that that was a war
and they will tell you how brutal how
Bloody it was and how impactful that was
on their life and when we're talking
about retention when we're talking about
the admissions in our military service
being at an all-time low I think we can
address that and resolve that by
restoring trust in our governmental
institutions by saying to them you will
not be deployed unless there is a
thoughtful deliberative process voted on
by 435 members of the United States
Congress that actually declares war
against an enemy and we have not done
that in the last 82 years I think we in
the state of New Hampshire have a chance
to push the Congress to get that done
and to implement a rule which protects
our National Guard members we can't do
it for the Air Force we can't do it for
the military broadly but we can do it
for the National Garden I think it's a
worthwhile thing for us to do here so I
thank you for your time chairman Moffet
I have to get to a study committee that
I'm 15 minutes late for but uh we'll
answer any questions that you may have
and appreciate your consideration of
this bill are there any pressing
questions then we'll let you get to your
other event uh representative power is
in the
house uh while she's approaching the
witness stand that's not the right word
the witness stand but
um uh I do need to point out it came up
earlier a declar last declaration of war
was not in 1941 it was in 1942 against
Bulgaria interestingly if you didn't
know that and also uh uh the the
declaration of war against Japan there
there was not three there was one
Congress person who uh only one who
voted against that declaration of war
and uh represent shff I'm sure you
ranking you uh you are correct Janette
Rankin that I was just going to say that
too being a history buff and Janette
uh yes and uh Janette Rankin was from
what state representative Wyoming
Montana all right that said uh rent
power uh rent power welcome thank you
for being here and um you have uh your
mic is on thank you and good morning Mr
chairman and honorable colleagues I
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
you today um regarding my concerns for
HB 229 for the record I am
representative Diane power from
Hillsboro County District 36
representing the towns of Brookline
Mason and Greenville there are three
topics that I'd like to address um this
morning first I will Define terms which
are critical in understanding the bill
language second I will highlight my
concerns with the bill as written and
third I I would like to offer a
potential solution so first topic is
definitions National Guard versus State
militia National Guard is a state-based
mil military force that becomes part of
the reserve components of the unit
United States Army and the United States
Air Force when activated for federal
missions as such the National Guard
units are under the Dual control of
state government and federal government
state militia or most commonly known as
State Defense Forces sdfs are distinct
from the reserves and the National Guard
in that they serve no federal function
in times of both War and Peace sdfs
remain solely under the control and
command of their Governors allowing the
governors to deploy them easily and
readily in the event of a natural or
man-made disaster today 23 States and
territories have organized militias New
Hampshire does not have a state
militia
status title 10 is federally controlled
and federally funded under the command
and control of the president of the
United
States operations that would fall under
title 10 status for example would be
Operation Desert Storm the state
partnership program National Guard
training in a foreign country like
Canada or England title 32 is state
controlled and federally funded under
the command and control of state or
territory
Governor examples would be natur natural
disaster response in state other
emergencies like coid um 19 response for
example drive-thru testing distribution
of supplies as well as drill weekends
and annual training stat side
approximately 96 to 98% of the National
Guard is federally funded also it's
notable to understand that equipment
acquired by the National Guard is
considered dual use for both wartime use
as well as domestic operations use this
equipment is used for training
operations which could be under title 10
or title 32 status and lastly State
active duty or sad is State controlled
and State St funded under the command
and control of the state or territory
Governor examples are natural dis
Disaster Response in state and
contingency operations like coid 19
testing next instrumentalities of war
that is defined as a vehicle vessel or
device designed primarily for military
service intended for use in such service
it may also include such
instrumentalities not designed primarily
for military service if its use subjects
the individual to a hazard particular to
the military service so the second topic
of um that I'd like to address is my
concerns with the bill as written I
understand the intent of the bill which
would prohibit the National Guard from
being deployed into active combat which
is a title 10 Duty without a formal
declaration of war by the United States
Congress unfortunately in my opinion
after analyzing the bill language I feel
that the bill misses the mark As written
and it does more than the stated intent
this would result in negative
consequences unintended consequences if
the current bill were to become law so
that said I will not address concerns
related to the potential loss of federal
funding
I'm just going to focus my my comments
here with regards to um the function of
the National
Guard
um so what are these negative unintended
consequences well first as written if
you would refer to to the bill print out
that um under Section Roman numeral 2
line 11 that's problematic active duty
combat is defined as one of the
following three functions so line 14
it's defined as partici participation in
an armed conflict second lines 15- 16
it's also defined as performance of a
hazardous service relating to an armed
conflict in a foreign State and thirdly
on line 17 it's defined as performance
of a Duty through an instrumentality of
War as such any of these three functions
can then be sub substituted for the term
on line 21 active duty combat but of
particular concern is line 17 and I'll
repeat it performance of a Duty through
an instrumentality of War this would
result in the prohibition of a number of
core functions of the National Guard so
concern number two as written this bill
would prohibit the National Guard State
partnership program under 10us code 321
training with friendly foreign countries
authorizes the state partnership program
which is primarily training in nature
the New Hampshire National Guard has a
state partnership program with both El
Salvador established in 2000 and Cabo
Verde which is uh Atlantic Islands off
the coast of Africa and that was
established in
2021 therefore the New Hampshire
National Guard State partnership program
would in fact in my opinion be
negatively affected by this bill
specifically by line 17 since training
involves the performance of Duty through
an instrumentality of War concern number
three as written this bill would
prohibit humanitarian Civic assistance
under 10 US code 401 humanitary and
Civic assistance provided in conjunction
with military operations again line 17
the performance of a Duty through an
instrumentality of War for example
Airlift Transportation loog Logistics
Force protection search and rescue which
utilizes for example helicopters heavy
equipment and water purification systems
for these same reasons stated previously
this function would also be affected by
the bill concern number four as written
lines 12 through 13 of the bill are also
Pro problematic referring to the term
Federal military service federal service
fall under both title 10 federally cont
controlled and federally funded as well
as title 32 which is State controlled
and federally funded in this context the
section it's unclear with regards to
control if this intent has to do with
control funding or both control and
funding concern number five section
Roman numeral four of the bill text
lines 27 through 28 is of concern it
reads nothing in this section shall
limit or prohibit the Governor from
consenting to the deployment of any New
Hampshire National Guard member on 32
USC section 904 so to be clear the
provision in section 4 ran numeral four
of the bill pertains to a single narrow
Authority Under title
32 specifically this Authority deals
exclusively with Homeland defense Duty
it's critical to understand that title
32 provides for many additional
authorities un which would undou
undoubtedly be negatively affected if
this bill were to become law as written
for example all training under 32s U us
code chapter 5 training entitled
training that would be impacted and
lastly my concern number six is any
function including training in the state
partnership program that occurs outside
of the contiguous United States Yukon it
must be in title 10 which is federally
controlled and federally funded to be
clear all national Guardsmen whether
it's the army or the Air National Guard
on duty outside of the United States
must be entitle 10 status any such
functions would be negatively impacted
if this bill were to become law not all
training occurs State Side some training
exercises occur in foreign countries
outside of the contiguous United States
for example training could occur in
Canada or England the instrumental
furthermore the instrumentality of War
definition section three on line 17
combined with the use on line 21 for
active duty combat that would
essentially prohibit the National Guard
from any title 10 Duty unless there was
a declaration of war this again it
includes training in a foreign country
including the National Guard State
partnership program because any of such
that such Duty it involves Vehicles
vessels defi devices or equipment all by
definition that are instrumentalities of
War which brings me to my third topic
and that's the solution and
um may I speak to to my solution which
is an amendment is that it's very brief
because it's very succinct I understand
there's an amendment that may come forth
shortly at executive session um but uh
while you're there uh and because you're
involved with the amendment if you could
speak quickly to that sure thank you it
will be quick so um based on my analysis
of this bill over the summer I I clearly
saw that there were some issues and
concerns with the bill as written so I
reached out to the prime sponsor
the prime sponsor understood my
concerns um and he supported my my
solution which is a very simple
Amendment and so um what I had OS go
ahead and and draft that and just to
reiterate s my concern is a significant
number of functions and missions
performed by the guard involves the use
of um vessels Vehicles devices or equ
equipment designated primarily for
military service they're all
instrumentalities of War therefore my
Amendment simply strikes line 17 which
which solves a lot of a lot of problems
and
um finally to be clear to reiterate once
again that if this bill were to move
forward with that that that line 17 it
would prohibit most National Guard
deployments to be able to conduct
training outside the contiguous United
States as well as as to provide training
and assistance um to foreign military
units abroad through the National Guard
State partnership program and to be
clear neither of these two are combat
functions so um with that I will
conclude my testimony and I'd also like
to say that um I did bring a a subject
matter expert um here with me today I'm
happy to answer any questions with
regards to my testimony but if you're
looking for a more comprehensive and
in-depth um answer to your questions I
would recommend that those questions be
deferred to Colonel power who is a
retired United States Air Force officer
and um he also served 28 years of his
time in the Massachusetts National
Guard thank you representative we have a
hard stop coming at
11:45 um I want to give the prime
sponsor an opportunity to say any words
if he wants to and then we will as as
quickly as we can uh go through the list
of people who would like to speak I'm
looking at some of the uh cards that I
have here these are from some folks were
here in February 3rd and have already
testified uh we will do what we can um
up to 11:45 uh represent pusk do you
sponsor
uh we have a hard stop we've already set
up for
uh at that time okay uh we will give you
that at 11:45 2 minutes uh at this time
um Colonel power uh is in the house I
recognize
him uh knowing that we want to let some
other folks have a chance to speak
before 11:45 if you could give us the
best of the
best I will do that I brief generals and
such that I know how to be brief and
concise uh good morning my name is uh
Eric power I'm from Brookline and I
served in the Air Force for 30 years I'm
a 30-year veteran 28 of those years my
first 28 years were in the Air National
Guard so I've been a Guardsman um I
served as a civil engineering officer
then a squadron commander then a
director of logistics and Engineering
for the state on the joint staff the
National Guard joint staff in
Massachusetts and I also spent a lot of
time at National Guard Bureau and at the
Pentagon doing joint planning so I'm
very familiar with with the statuses of
everyone and how important that is um I
also you know did planning for many
exercises and over a dozen actual
natural disaster emergencies so I know
this the that statuses are important and
I'm very proud to have been have been a
citizen Airman because the National
Guard is special it there are two of the
seven components in the United States
military that are guard it's the Army
guard and the and the uh air
guard the reason that the guard is
special is because it has dual mission
of supporting the governor locally in
the state or territory as well as um
doing the operational Mission federally
and there has to be a balance there and
currently there is um the balance is
actually sort of a gentleman's gentle
woman's agreement on how many national
Guardsmen can be deployed out of of a
state and that's not really a good place
to be so I think this is this makes a
lot of sense this bill so I'm in favor
of this bill um I think it would help
bring the discussion forward help change
the way that we do business in declaring
war and um would also help balance the
important role that the National Guard
has in its state Mission as well as its
Federal Mission you know we've seen a
lot of uh more recent disasters and you
know people people think it's climate
change or whatever it is but the
National Guard has been used more and
more and more in the past 10 15 years
especially during my
career um so I would like to also state
that I think the bill as written does
need to have that line 17 deleted
because um you know when you're talking
about instrumentalities of War that's
basically military equipment and there's
no real distinction Guardsmen use that
all the time whether they're do in the
United States or they're doing it
overseas so I think deleting that would
actually Remedy and make this a great
Bill and would be good for the National
Guard um in New Hampshire and I think it
would start the conversation so that we
would have the National Guard being able
to fulfill its dual Mission role in a
more responsible
manner um saying that I I'll take any
questions I appreciate the opportunity
to speak to
you thank you for your great insights uh
uh
questions uh quickly representative hgan
um yes a very quick one we uh hopefully
it's quick in Lin's uh you mro um
leading line 17 but line 15- 16 a is
participation in an armed conflict and
there's no specification of where that
armed conflict is certainly we could at
least in theory have an armed conflict
USA but then they make a point
specifying second performance of a haard
hazardous service related to an armed
conflict in a foreign state so what's
what's the difference between
participation and uh performing
performance of a hazardous surface
related to an armed conflict sure I can
mention that that comes back a lot the
Army ends to do that and my Army
colleagues the soldiers and the Army
guard um front line folks are usually
what they consider the participants in
the armed conflict then you have combat
support which are the folks that are
behind the lines supporting it but not
out of Harm's Way and so that's what
it's saying so you're not going to go to
the front line and you're not going to
be directly supporting the front lines
with without a declaration of war and I
think that's a very good bill to
pass okay thank you uh Colonel and thank
you for your service okay we have about
seven minutes what I want to do at this
time is uh go through from the top of
the deck here and uh if you've already
spoken in February i' would ask that you
not speak again uh again this is not a
hearing is a courtesy to those of you
who are here I want to give you as many
as we can a chance to say a few words
when we heard that this in February 3rd
there were many veterans who were very
very serious and I'll never forget
looking at their faces and how important
this bill was to them that's why we
retained it that's why we're spending
time on it today and that's why uh we we
will come to an exact session at noon
time and vote on it um Derek po Derek is
Derek
here you said you had some written
testimony uh is that something that
you've already passed out
okay if you could uh share your written
testimony that would be great that'll
give us time to uh review that uh as we
go into exec session and while you're
doing that I'm going to look to uh Colin
Colin is Colin here uh Colin would you
like to take up to a
new Colin and Derek thank you my name is
Colin Mitchell I'll be brief and
succinct all my opinions and uh
statements I'm going to make are my own
and no one else's I have to say this
because I'm currently serving in your
National Guard these are my own opinions
not the guards I've been a Staff
Sergeant in the Army National Guard for
over 12 years now mostly in Illinois
many um approximately one New Hampshire
I served on both flood duties in
Illinois as well as Co response and
there was a suggestion earlier that
um having more soldiers would not have
reduced loss of life or other instances
during um flood incidents and I can tell
you from doing flood Duty that every
single soldier is necessary and when
you're standing on a levy that has the
illino river risen to the top of it and
the other side is someone's home and
you're sandbagging to make sure that
that Levy doesn't disintegrate and
destroy their livelihood uh every single
pack is necessary um on the co response
we had far fewer people than we would
have liked to have um I was doing
analytics work we were deciding how to
get the most doses of vaccine into the
few number of freezers that we had
available that could reduce the VAC the
temperature to the very low uh
temperature needed for the vaccines to
be viable uh I wish I had more people
with me doing that um I have two degrees
in Applied Mathematics and that was
still very very difficult so the idea
that more people being in their home
state doing work to defend and support
that home state the idea that that isn't
a necessity um I don't think is
factually accurate uh thank you it's all
I
have thank you uh Nolan is Nolan still
here Nolan
peler
chair Mr chair Mr chair over here uh yes
rep Granger is here I don't know if he
was in that stack oh okay uh uh go go
representative uh Nolan poer I'll make
this very very short uh I did not make
it here in February so uh I'm a little
disappointed in myself but I'm here now
um I don't always agree with Democrats
or Republicans and don't even get me
started with with
Libertarians but uh what I I think we
can agree on here is that all of you
sitting around here at this table are
here because you want to do what's best
for New Hampshire and its community and
its people the National Guard is made up
of those people our neighbors our
friends our family and if you want them
to put their life on the line we need a
declaration of war so please do your job
and protect our community thank
you thank you and representative Granger
thank you for your uh forbearance uh
co-sponsor uh representative Granger
straford District 2 uh thank you Mr
chair um so I want to talk a little bit
about uh one of the uh former co- I
don't know if he's still considered a
co-sponsor or not um he he left the
honorable Joshua agitant was one of the
co-sponsors of the bill I whether he's
still or not I don't know but um the one
of the last things he did in the state
house was probably the best thing I've
ever seen anyone do from the well which
is he went down and during unanimous
consent he listed and had a moment of
silence where he just listed every New
Hampshire resident who died in Iraq
that's 23 people all right and you can
say with you know we need the National
Guard for National Security we need this
that and the other thing but can anybody
seriously say with a straight face that
the Iraq War was about National Security
that the Iraq that New Hampshire was
served by those guys dying in Iraq that
we actually needed those guys to
sacrifice their lives for the protection
of New Hampshire was the Iraq War
protecting New Hampshire or America you
can think you can solve that for
yourself you can think about it for
yourself but he he left some people out
because and this is not this isn't his
fault at all um because there is no way
to keep track of all of uh the actual
casualties of Iraq the fatalities from
Iraq because a lot of them died by
Suicide and uh we have some uh suicide
statistics but we don't have all of them
um we can't be sure for sure and and so
we there's a lot of theories about why
veterans often commit suicide but there
is the elephant in the room the one that
uh we should probably pay attention to
and that is the pointlessness and the
insipid nature of the wars
themselves if you go to a place and you
have a reason to be there for instance
you're defending your Homeland you're
protecting the people you love you're uh
freeing slaves you're uh beating out the
oppressor and say and you know releasing
yoke of pharaoh whatever the case may be
you have a reason to be there and even
though you may see horrible things you
might see some awful disastrous things
you might engage in some atrocities
yourself you'll know that you at least
had a purpose and you can actually sort
those
out I went to Kuwait in
2012 what was the purpose of me being in
Kuwait in
2012 the waren the Gulf War ended in
1991 and this goes for every single War
so you talk about now the Afghanistan
war right so you're thinking about the
Afghanistan war had a really good point
at the beginning we were attacked seems
like a justification but then you
realize that we were we had a war
against al- Qaeda that turned into a war
against the Taliban and the Taliban
weren't even involved in the 911
terrorist attacks whatsoever and then
you realize that oh wait we're trying to
teach afghanis to be Americans somehow
that we have National Guardsmen in
Afghanistan trying to teach afghanis to
be Americans they're on the opposite
side of the planet they don't even know
where New Hampshire
is they they don't they've never heard
of New Hampshire they they know us
because that's where the bombs are
coming from all right and and this is
every war all right and it weighs on
your soul and that's probably why the
veteran suicide rate is so ridiculous
all right so so imagine now I had a
pretty easy time in my deployment
because I was only in Kuwait uh no one's
Cho in Kuwait but what if you were the
guy that was in was the guy helping the
Saudi pilot bomb the yeni water
treatment facility all right and what if
you now Pilots are generally pretty
smart they can probably do their own
research and you look it up and you say
gee why am I in Yemen helping the Saudis
bomb a water treatment facility in Yemen
and then you look it up and you see Oh
look The reason I'm in Yemen helping the
Saudis is because the Saudis are mad at
America because America made a deal with
Iran that isn't exactly a very good
reason to be doing what you're doing and
once you see the consequences of that
that that hurts that's a weight on your
soul all right over 100,000 kids women
and innocent people died from chalera
kalala is an awful way to go it's an
awful way to go none of those people
were a threat to New Hampshire none of
those people were a threat to America
they hadn't even they had no idea they
couldn't point out America on a map this
is the poorest country in the Middle
East Al Qaeda wasn't there there was the
houthis you you guys can think for
yourself do you know who the houth are
do you know why we're bombing the houth
if so there's a lot of you know there's
been a lot of claims that we already
have a method for reigning in the
executive we can go through Congress
through the authorization for the use of
military force if this is the result we
get from the amount of control that we
have over the Executive then what good
is it you know yes I'm glad that we have
aumf and Congress can pull the pur
strings but they don't so we need more
oversight on where we're sending our
sending our kids and as New Hampshire we
we can't say we can't send active duty
overseas that's not our prerogative
that's not our wheelhouse
we can definitely tell them that we
can't send our National Guard kids
overseas we need them here thank
you thank
[Applause]
you thank you representative Granger and
thank you for your service all right uh
the prime sponsor had asked for two
minutes uh and then we will break until
high noon and then we'll come back and
exact this
measure uh welcome representative
pusk thank you Mr chair uh for the
record representative John pusk uh
Rockingham 13
Dairy
um I agreed to uh the amendment because
without the amendment it restricts the
National Guard I'd also like to address
the fact that this
bill is a bipartisan
bill as a lot of folks know I've been
here a couple years representative adant
and I rarely ever saw to eye on any
issues but as representative Sheriff
will
attest uh we get together once in a
while on Veterans
issues
uh and he is my Prime co-sponsor on this
bill uh I have brothers Vietnam veterans
who are
here we did not have a
war but we served
conflict as representative schliff will
attest it was a
war we had friends brothers sisters who
died my thing is we need to have a
declaration of war to get into these
conflicts and get out of these conflicts
successfully and I'm hoping you will
support this along with the
Amendment and move it forward to the
house so we can have this discussion
among the 400 of us who can really dig
into it and I suspect it'll take a long
time so thank you ladies and gentlemen
of the
committee I appreciate your
thoughtfulness on this and
uh that's my two minutes thank you
before we break does anyone have have a
question for the prime
sponsor uh Rob sanan I just have a a
question to yourself and everybody in
the room really can I see a show a hands
who supports the
Bill thank
you okay uh we will at this time we'll
break until 12: noon it's 12 minutes
until 12:00 noon we'll come back and we
you
minutes
yeah
chairman motion make a motion can we get
time for you to take a
motion oh oh okay uh I know there's
amend Amendment perating so I'm going to
take the amendment motion and then and
okay thanks for uh I would have got
there event myself at the
son get
went
that's and uh
they
will okay folks it being
1201 by that clock uh let's get to uh
the reason that we're here was is to
exact this measure and uh and surely
take a vote on it one way or the other
uh my understanding is those of you
whove been here know that there was a
talk of an amendment uh representative
Pani uh do you have a motion that you
wish to make yes yes Mr chair thank you
for recognizing me I'd like to uh make a
motion to accept the uh submit the
amendment
2023-24 6h that was given to everyone I
believe here um and I think it it's
some
oh and I just think it's something you
may enhance the
bill okay uh is I heard there's a second
uh uh representative gagy uh uh very
excitedly wants to second that
motion uh representative pone would you
like to speak to your
motion thank you Mr chair I really don't
have a lot to say on this what I'd like
to do is refer I if possible my time to
representative power that uh uh
initially designed the bill the
amendment I mean the chair will support
your uh recommendation to defer your
comment to U representative power and we
we will recognize representative power
who is uh obviously spent some time on
this a lot of time appreciate your time
and interest on this representative
power uh the amendment was submitted by
represent
pman um we at this time uh if you would
please speak to that propos proposed
amendment thank you Mr chairman so um
everybody has a copy of the the
amendment and if you compare that to the
bill language the amendment simply
deletes line 17 which um states in the
definition of active duty combat it
eliminates the the provision um for the
performance of a Duty through an
instrumentality of war and as I had
explained um
previously why this is important is that
a significant number of functions and
missions performed by the National Guard
in fact involves the use of
instrumentalities of War which are
defined as Vehicles vessels devices or
equipment designated primar primarily
for military
service and um as I stated previously
that by in including this language this
bill um would prohibit most National
Guard deployments in summary as I had
stated previously to conduct training
outside of the contiguous United States
as well as the ability to provide
training and assistance to foreign
military
units abroad that's out of this country
through the National Guard State
partnership program and also as I'd like
to further note that these two functions
they're not combat um functions in in
nature and uh lastly I will add that um
under Roman numeral 2 of the bill line
11 the participation in an armed
conflict um in in L that's line 14 and
on line
15 the performance of a hazardous
service related to an armed conflict in
a foreign State I I believe that's
sufficient to uphold the intent of this
bill and as I said the um re retention
of that line 17 performance of a Duty
through an instrumentality a war that
goes beyond the intent of the bill and
actually breaks things um so that that
that's my explanation of of the
amendment and I um I would hope that um
this amendment would be accepted
thank you Mr chair will you take
questions for me uh sure
uh just just to be clear for me and for
the rest of this representative uh in
the original measure what what only
thing that's being deleted is that line
17 which states performance of a Duty
War so um with regards to Roman numeral
section two of the bill which Encompass
lines 11 through
17 the way that OS drafted the amendment
is we're just
replacing those lines with what's in the
amend Amendment which essentially simply
deletes line 17 of the original bill
which again removes this performance of
a Duty through an instrument ity of War
because that goes back to this
definition of active duty combat right
that's defined as one of the three um
functions and then if you go down in
section
three active duty combat is referenced
in Roman numeral three of the bill and
so we're just
eliminating performance of Duty through
an instrumentality
War
is that
clear the bill remains exactly the same
we're just striking line 17 in the
original bill that's
it okay representative if if we were to
adopt this amendment which hasn't it's
been approved by OS it has an amending
number 2276
H uh I'm reading the amendment and I'm
seeing where it'll replace the language
in the original bill I think that's
fairly clear the the piece of this that
is not quite clear to me is that the
amendment says nothing about line
17 because on line one of the amendment
it says that the section two is replaced
with the following it's just the way
that they they draft it we're we're
replacing that part and we're just we're
not
including
we we're replacing section two with
section
two right if you look Mr chairman it
deletes line 17 which is number three
yeah performance of a Duty through an
instrum I see I see okay so the by
replacing uh section two the way that
the amendment does that uh that answers
my question okay so that this amendment
replaces 17 and there's no need for any
other okay
correct it's too it's just the way that
they drafted it okay I got it does
anybody else have any is that clear to
everyone else represent Rollins thank
you Mr chairman does that include uh B
under uh that does that include 18
because that's part of section
two no no no b b remains B remains
representative any other questions for
the the D
drafter okay thank thank you
representative turn your mic on please
sorry okay I would just like to clarify
that line 17 the the the number three is
not replaced it's just being taken out
am I
correct that is correct representative
okay all right thank
you thanks represent sabert um anything
else
for representative
power all right CA thank you uh for
assisting us with that this is
representative P Monty's uh proposed
amendment um I have a sense of anybody
else have any is there anything else on
the amendment rep Manion so uh from my
understanding the instrumentality of
Wars like defined especially by the
Department of Defense and the IRS as
something as like uh how to find
somebody as a part of combat Duty like
so if you were to be uh uh allowed
Hazard pay or combat pay that is also
the same language that they use it
wouldn't cover just driving in a Jeep in
like Mexico you would have to be uh you
know participating in some type of armed
conflict even if you're uh not in the
area it would be like uh midair
refueling uh over like outside of a
combat zone but supplying a combat zone
or convoys of trucks supplying a combat
zone but not setting foot inside you
would qualify as combat pay that's my
take on this but uh if this amendment
you know is makes everybody in the
committee happy then uh that's
fine anything else on the amendment
representative uh gagy I see you you
poised but uh thank you thank you uh Mr
chairman it it was just like a
paratrooper getting hazardous duty duty
pay for being a paratrooper whether he's
not uh thank you for that that being
from a nav man anything else
representative
shiff how can I follow that um thank you
Mr chairman Mr chairman I want to thank
the member from Brook line for bringing
this amendment in and I also want to
thank the colonel for being with her
today and for his testimony I'm going to
vote against the amendment not that I'm
opposed to what it's trying to do but I
would rather see this amendment
Incorporated a new bill and to have it
maybe go into rules for a late filing
and bring it back as a complete Bill and
let us Ved it all at one time I know the
CH had a little bit of confusion at
first as did I when I fir on my first
blush I think this does improve the bill
but I'd rather see it as a total package
that we could take up at one time and be
able to vet it this is an important bill
we can see by the number of people that
have turned out today and we appreciate
them being here but and again this is no
reflection on the member is just what I
like to see as part of one Bill thank
you Mr chairman
thank you representative any anything
else the last comment that that I will
make is that uh the representative just
said that he thought that the new
language did improve the bill my sense
is that the members uh see this as an
improvement uh W if this amendment were
to pass then we would take the bill up
as amended if the amendment does not
pass we'll take the original Bill up and
we will vote on that uh if this does
improve if this does improve the
language and I uh am inclined to support
it I rule of thumb being that uh even if
you don't like the the the measure if a
Amendment improves it uh we want to see
the best measure go forward if it goes
forward that is my take on it anything
else before we uh have the
clerk run the role uh saying no other
the comments uh Madam clerk if you would
uh uh
sorry I I just wanted to make a a quick
statement before we go into the voting
um active voting session um even with
the amendment I'm a little concerned
over some of the things in the bills uh
or in this bill and I just want to make
sure that we that if anything did happen
it like it we I could talk um
constitutionally speaking I'm concerned
about this bill um because technically
the that we received from um Warren
Perry uh Deputy adjutant General had
note or had noted that um the National
Guard is called to active duty under the
provisions of title 10 of the US code
and it says in times of War of National
Emergency declared by Congress or when
otherwise authorized by law um and he
pointed that out to us um all and then
on top of that I worry that if we
require a declaration of war it would
seriously hinder our Armed Forces
ability to swiftly respond to a national
emergency and it could limit our support
of the Armed
Forces um for for anybody else who's
overseas and I don't want to do that and
it could potentially seriously affect
the federal funding to our state um
those are really big concerns that I
have here um even if the bill is amended
um however I also really want to speak
to all of the veterans and citizens
who reached out to me on this specific
bill um I heard you and in late August I
had to take an emergency trip back to
Kansas to attend my Uncle Mike's funeral
uh he was a marine and he was enlisted
quite young he had to get his father to
sign off on him being enlisted and he
served as a tunnel rat um so he was over
there he was a purle heart Purple Heart
veteran um
and the the lack of support that he felt
it really stretched deep and he had many
medical issues throughout his the rest
of his life because of it um his
personal story weighed on me a lot when
I was considering all of this bill
um so I want all of you to know who
reached out to me thank you and I heard
you um and I understand but I still
can't overrule those other concerns that
I have here um additionally to those
that submitted this Bill thank you I
majored in
Psychology but my school focused on
psychological research and one of our
ideas was that sometimes with research
you need to chip away or present
something that gets thought moving and
discussion happening and it lays a
foundation for other research to be
built off of and it's slow progress but
over time eventually those hypotheses
are tested and proven or disproven and I
feel like this bill to those who choose
to listen can provide some of that
foundational work um understanding that
New Hampshire and all over the country
veterans have a higher suicide rate than
average than the average citizen
population I ask those here to recognize
and understand that this bill directly
identifies one specific area where our
veterans feel they are lacking that
support not only did many veterans who
contact me identify this but they wanted
to me to support this bill to prevent
others feeling from what what they had
felt and this is absolutely crucial to
listening to the psychology behind all
of this so anybody who has the authority
to do so or can talk to people in a
federal level in any way shape or form I
think we need to be bringing up and
bringing attention to this bill and this
particular interest that uh that has
been generated here um I believe we
would be SM smart to listen and to pay
attention and to lean into this and act
proactively to support and better serve
those who have served our country if
anyone here has the power to act upon
that please take this bill to heart um I
vote no or I'm going to vote no uh due
to the reason stated but I thank all who
submitted this so thank you
sorry thank you representative Lloyd and
bless uh your Uncle Mike who I simplify
to him
uh it's important to remember these
folks like you just did thank thank you
for
that anything else before we run the
role saying nothing uh Madame clerk if
you would uh do a roll call vote on the
amendment a roll call vote on the
adoption of amendment
2023 d227 68
representative Rollins yes
representative
lungren oh gone uh cat uh Representative
catosaurus
no representative
lebit
I representative Harley
yes representative
gagy yes representative
ponti yes
representative finny yes representative
Manion
no Representative shirtliff no
representative uh Mass Miller is
actually Chris Schulz right yes
representative Carrie uh my vote though
is
no no it's no okay representative Boris
no uh representative KY yes
representative near who who is replaced
by no you're you're
your okay I vote no on the amendment
okay and this is
toll oh Horgan so it's Horan
okay okay and your no yes uh yes
no okay representative Lloyd no
representative O'Neal no and
representative cber
no and uh let's
yes
eight two three four five six seven
eight N9 10
11 so we have
um eight in favor and 11 opposed the
amendment fails so the amendment fails
uh eight in favor 11 opposed that brings
us back to the original measure uh which
we need to take action on I'm looking
for a motion uh perhaps uh uh re Sher
you said you had an individual with a
motion perhaps uh that was uh apologies
that was me I probably spoke out turn
but thank you okay so now that the
amendment has been voted down ripson vyd
uh you have a a motion a subsequent
motion no it was uh just to uh speak to
what I had just spoken to and um
unfortunately I I'm still voting no
thank you okay represent Sheriff thank
you Mr chairman i' vote i' I'd move itl
in expedient to
somebody say
something the motion um has been
seconded uh original motion by uh
resident of shortliffe motion on the
floor in front of the committee is itl
and expedient to legislate uh
representative would you care to speak
to your motion just briefly because
we've been here a while and I think
everybody's patience first of all let me
say that the prime sponsor of this bill
is not just a friend I consider him a
good friend and I've been honored to
serve as co-sponsors of other bills that
he's done and uh I've got tremendous
respect for him and all the uh
co-sponsors of this
bill as the member said this bill needs
a little bit of work and I think this
amendment that we heard about could help
it but I wonder if there are other parts
of this bill that we don't understand
and what I would recommend to my good
friend from dairy is if the bill should
uh not passed today with a
recommendation of OTP to go back to the
rules committee and mention that this
information that came up at this hearing
and asked for a late filing to file the
bill again so that the bill could be
considered in as totality with the
amendment and I would just say Mr
chairman I would ask the committee to
please vote for the itl but the
recommendation to my friend from Gary is
to bring it back through rules with the
improvements thank you representative uh
your comments are have been recorded and
your recommendation is uh is well taken
it's also uh being recorded uh uh is
being
streamed uh any anything else uh would
anyone else here to speak to the uh itl
oh motion representative uh finny M I
speaking to the motion or or can I speak
to the bill we disc we're discussing the
motion which is itl so you can speak uh
you're not speaking to the motion you're
speaking to the to the bill Bill the
Merit of the bill
okay um I'm going to vote against the
itl um I think it's important that as as
we heard earlier our terms were already
were already set for us we're only
specifically talking about
sending an New Hampshire no excuse me
New Hampshire uh uh uh service people
into um active combat areas not talking
about training uh I I served 10 years
I'm in the garden in this state and I
was a construction engineer I was sent
to Al Salvador I've been to United Air
Emirates those were not combat areas
those are training areas those those
training things don't change we're only
specifically talking about being sent
into active combat areas which is what
our infantry units in New Hampshire have
already been doing they've done at least
three that I can think of off top of my
head um and considering the the you know
current events happening in the world
where where're potentially saying that
our state is okay with with the federal
government without any type of of act
from Congress to tell you know Governor
sununu or whoever in the future that we
will send troops to Israel we that we
that we're going to send troops to
Ukraine and then it becomes our problem
we we weren't even involved the problem
is is that we're involving too much of
ourselves in in you know um excuse me
the the happenings in foreign states and
it's the bill is specific in line 15 the
performance of a hazardous service
relating to an armed conflict in a
foreign State no one is talking about
what's happening here we're only talking
about being sent into foreign countries
to to to subsequently subsidize foreign
States you know through their you know U
through their government through their
military and through our training we are
still providing Our Lives to them not
for our own interests but for theirs and
that's not what I'm not what
what the mission
is uh people that serve in the guard are
to serve the state of New Hampshire not
to serve foreign interests or corporate
interests it's only for armed conflict
that's the only thing that this bill is
talking about thank
you thank you representative uh rep
representative Manion uh again thank you
uh so I oppose the itl motion uh for
several reasons I'm going to outline uh
Congress cannot uh hand over its
constitutionally delegated power to
another brand of government that would
be like scotus writing legislation pus
confirming their judge appointments the
process requires a Constitutional
Amendment ratified by the states contact
our representation has not worked for
over 20 years the very activists that
came up with defend the guard tried that
route for decades Congress has failed US
senator ran Paul's latest vote to repeal
the 2001 aumf garnered 10 votes in the
Senate the legislation uh legislative
branch is not willing to De clawback
their war war makinging Authority from
the executive because it Shields them
from the consequences that they'd have
to live with for actually voting for war
the 2001 aumf is still active with no
clearly defined targets duration theater
of operation or Victory conditions
military campaigns have been launched in
at least 22 countries largely classified
it's used to justify coups across
regions some of which involved working
with Isis and al-Qaeda in theaters such
as Libya and Syria so the argument that
we're fighting terrorism with these aumf
we we fight with the terrorists uh in
Syria speaking of Syria uh the the
Louisiana National Guard came under
rocket attacks from IR Iranian backed
militants this past spring and what are
they these troops doing in Syria they're
guarding private oil
wells so we go we talk about funding and
losing potential uh funding here uh
Congress handles funding uh it's the
word we keep hearing the fiscal not says
that it puts the money at risk this
would be political suicide for Shaheen
papis kustard to vote against the
National Guard uh congressman gsar and
Congressman Massie have gone on record
to say that there are no active
discussions at all in Congress to
withhold the money for any National
Guard unit it would be absolute
political
suicide uh during the during my
presentation to esvac I requested the
Bill's opposition be removed uh but not
necessarily to change to support I just
wanted the opposition remove it became
rapidly apparent that the department of
military Affairs has an oversized
influence on an organization whose
mission is to support veterans nothing
can support veterans more than
preventing service members from being
abused by the United States Department
of Defense and coming home broken after
the presentation several non-voting
members approached me to say they
supported the bill this has been the
same reaction I've received at vfw's
American Legions and even via email and
phone calls after I published my New
Hampshire Journal article and again in
my local paper uh the bill is outright
adored by just about every person who
hears about it many of whom are veterans
there's a massive disconnect between the
voting members of esvac and the veterans
they are charged with representing it is
my belief that the department of
military Affairs and Department of
Veteran Services being combined as a
conflict of interest and high on high on
my list of priorities to in 2025 to
remedy when I run again thankfully this
uh Bill's Journey brought this to my
attention this is a bill whose time has
come over the decades several states
have realized that waiting for Congress
to do the right thing is a Fool's errand
we're looking at things like civil asset
forfeiture is being overturned at the
state level uh States uh legalizing abis
for medical use is something the federal
government prohibits the states need to
claw back their Authority here uh there
states legalized gay marriage for
decades decades before scotus made a
ruling on it various Sanctuary policies
whether it's uh immigration or second
amendment these are also pushed by the
states asserting their 10th Amendment
rights uh defend the guard fills a
similar Gap to say enough is enough we
tried we're tired of the pentagon's
budget saving measure of exploiting
state militias if the Department of
Defense can't recruit enough active duty
army or can't afford to house and train
them these are symptoms of the exact
problem defend the guard is trying to
remedy we are stretched too thin in too
many regions fighting Wars that are
Undeclared our men or women are coming
home sometimes in boxes other times
physically and emotionally scarred for
life all all the while states are left
without their citizen should soldiers
during emergencies and for what can
anyone in this room say we were better
off our actions in Afghanistan 20 years
of Bloodshed bloodshed the country back
to the Taliban now better equipped with
abandoned gear what about Iraq a war
based on a lie where much of our gift uh
gifted equipment and even Iraqi soldiers
we trained ended up joining
Isis so once again fighting terrorism
but creating more terrorism instituting
a caliphate worse than Saddam ever was
ongoing regime change around the entire
region from Libya where we assisted Isis
and Al-Qaeda and overthrowing Gaddafi
left the area in chaos a literal slave
trade is active in the streets of this
country country now what about Syria
another regime change conflict
predicated on a lie where we once again
train representative we're getting into
a lot of
specific uh uh National policy
deployment issues and and and we we need
to exec this and and if you could focus
on the merits of the specific language
thank you thank you I'll skip right here
uh there's a nebulous description of our
guard uh missions where we say we're
supporting our allies and protecting us
interests it sounds Noble at face value
except sometimes our allies have been
Isis and Al-Qaeda uh and sometimes we
demo our high Mars battalions as if
allies so so Congress is happy with the
status quo the executive regardless of
party party in power is happy with the
status quo just like with term or age
limits or balanced budget amendment or
prohibiting stock trades or with holding
Congressional pay until they pass a
budget nothing will change no matter how
much we beg Congress it's time for the
states to act it times for us to act so
I ask we vote against itl and make
another motion thank you thank you
representative anyone
else I would just like to make a
statement that I disagree with this bill
um and a big part of it is you know it's
not just political
suicide but it's because it actually
affects people it weighs on my soul to
cut funding for veterans which you know
helps with PTS D and they're really
doing a lot of work on that now and you
know compared to in the past you know in
the past 20 years they've really come a
long way and they've got a ways to go
but it it weighs on my soul to do that
that we can save a lot of lives that way
so and then on top of that the money I
could lead this see this bill as causing
Congress to become even more jury Mander
um you know and corporations puming more
money into elections than they already
do so I think that's a huge part of this
inherent problem as well and this bill
does not address that so I will be
voting against it but I just wanted to
make that statement and thanks to all
the veterans out there and the ones who
don't support this bill as well so thank
else uh
repr uh we'll give you this courtesy
you're not a a normal a regular member
of this committee but uh we do try we
want to give you a chance to speak if
you if you so desire oh thank you um
this bill seems to be um encourage well
if it if this passes um it would and
other states to encourage con Congress
to formerly declare war and well
certainly I certainly wouldn't trust
this particular Congress which is
totally dysfunctional as we probably
everybody in both sides I agree but
sentive I think the nature of the
current Congress is not part of the
issue here with what we're talking about
in executing the language of this bill
if you if you could finish your remarks
please yes but declaring war is all
kinds of legal and economic effects and
I don't necessarily agree that our
economy would even be on a war we
probably would have to step up just like
the 1940s I think that's um a very
dangerous thing to be declaring war
because had all kinds of uh impact on
civil liberties and other domestic
things so it's probably not as not that
the way we' been doing is great but
probably be even worse if we had uh
something if this was something like
this was in in effect in our state in
the other states so thanks thank you
representative seeing no other hands uh
yes repres I'll be quick on this one I
guess uh my concern is still outstanding
in that I do worry that not being able
to send our uh National Guard to assist
our troops who are current currently
serving overseas if there was an
emergency like how would we be able to
first thank you sentive before we run
the uh Madam clerk runs the uh role my
final comment um I want to thank
everybody who's here uh I want to thank
the sponsors for the huge amount of time
that they and others have spent on this
I think this is an important uh issue
that we're shining a light on and having
an important discussion uh on which
we're about to vote I honestly have been
un undecided on it uh we retained it in
large part because of how seriously we
took the many veterans who came in on
February 3rd and passionately uh asked
us to cons consider this and we spent a
lot of time today we made extra time to
uh fully allow folks to answer our
questions and address this I will say
that uh we're hearing different things
with regard to esvac State veterans
advisory Council uh ranion uh I think
fairly points out that there are many
members of the subsidiary organizations
who don't who do support the bill I have
to say that I the intent of uh esvac as
an advisory council is to help us out
with with with uh legislation such as
this and where do they stand on it and
knowing that many individuals support
the bill the fact that esvac itself
apparently unanimously uh opposes the
bill has to wait has to Bear some way at
least with me uh I do want to thank
representative Granger uh for your
remarks earlier uh honestly it I think
it moved the needle it was uh Le
speaking for myself I it was very well
put and important to uh get on people's
radar screens last call for comments
before we run the
vote sing uh Madame clerk if you would
role representative Rollins
no Representative lungren
no Representative korus no
Representative levit
no representative
Harley yes so wait yeah I'm I'm so sorry
I'm I'm a little confused is this uh is
this voting on the motion to itl or this
is voting on the motion to itl so
okay sorry I vote no okay so
representative Harley your vote is
no correct yes okay Representative gagy
no Representative
ponti no representative finny no
representative Manion no representative
Shir
yes representative uh let's see we have
a substitute for Mass Milla Schultz
Schultz
yes representative Boris
no representative Carrie yes
representative maner who is that a
substitute tki okay tersi votes yes on
the it okay representative
tol I vote Yes on the well I'm represent
Oran I yes on the it okay representative
Judy no representative Lloyd yes
representative O'Neal yes representative
cber yes
okay five six seven eight and the
chairman see yep eight and one two three
four five six seven eight
n the same as the other one except we've
got one extra vote because uh we have
lungren
here what was the Chairman's vote chair
votes
no
okay 12 to eight that's what I have
against 12 to eight against itl I'd like
OTP subsequent motion from uh
your motion yeah uh motion
before every single bit and then the
stuff I had to cut out
too and there's a
second uh representative jery seconds
it
day
so the OTP motion has been made and
seconded de uh R Manion you've already
uh indicated that you have said all that
you need to say uh represent Judy Happ
more would you you care to speak as a
seconding
member oh thank you yes Mr chair I
second not only I understand the bill
and uh secondly I received so many email
from the veterans and I always been
someone who really care about the
veterans even in the commercial when I
see them in TV and uh those guy don't
have no
no LMS or burning I feel it in my in my
I thank you
representative before we run the rooll
call is uh representative shli thank you
Mr chairman um first let me say there's
nobody and I know you agree to this
there is absolutely nobody that hates
War more than a veteran and it's hard
for me to believe I left Vietnam 55
years ago
but there hasn't been a day the vietnams
ever left me I appreciate the sponsor
and what he was trying to do with this
bill I honestly don't believe this
already bill is quite ready for prime
time as the previous representative from
Brookline told us and so I'm going to be
pass thank you
representative anyone
else saying No Hands Madam clerk if you
would run the role the question is
229 so ought to pass HB
229 no amendments the original
bill so representative Rollins
yes Representative lungren no
Representative catoris no representative
levit
I representative
Harley yes representative gagy
yes representative
ponti yes representative finny yes
representative Manion yes Representative
shirtliff no representative uh let's see
schz
SCH all right and your vote no no okay
representative Boris
yes representative carry no
representative maner
who is uh
terisi ohe no no okay representative tol
representative Oregon and subs for
represent toll so I vote no on the a to
pass okay representative
Judy yes
okay representative Lloyd
no representative O'Neal no
representative Sebert no
okay the chair the chair
yes
avoid I need to can I double check the
vote please so with our substitutes
Schultz you voted
no
um uh Miner who is um
delisi you voted h no okay and uh tol
who is Horgan you voted I also voted no
no
okay
recation
yes the final vote is 10 to 10 on the
OTP motion so that is how it will go to
the to the Full House we need a report
uh for uh R you'll write a
report uh in favor of the OTP uh we need
a a uh corresponding report for itl uh
representative schliff will do
that okay so that is our one bill we
finished uh I'm going to adjourn this
and I would ask that the members stay
around we have an announcement or two uh
uh from the clerk yes so um since the
issue of mental health did come up we
have um Stella Laro from the Veterans
Administration who has offered to put
together a presentation from the
veterans we have a representative from
the VA Stella Laro who's offered to put
together some individuals from the
Veterans Administration to talk about
what mental health services are
available to Veterans and to answer any
questions we have regarding Mental
Health Services if this is something the
committee would like to do I'd be glad
to reach back out to her to um set a
date we might be able to do that chair
do you have a date in mind I I do not
but uh when we all come back in
January something so I will try to um
get something together for January
secondarily we had two veter reach out
to this committee um during the time we
were not meeting both uh veterans had
their issues addressed by the VA so U my
understanding is they were successful so
U that's good news and thank you for
everyone who reached out to try to
support these
veterans thank you for the work that you
did on that too representative thank you
madam
clerk thank you all we'll uh see you
down the
five